Hi my name is Grace Helbig if you did not know, now you know your life is different now!
Youtube is a, um.
*bom* *bing*
ohh no...
I've been making videos on youtube
for over ten years and the land-
scape of youtube is changing. It's sometimes for
creators... often times for creators. Its hard to keep up.
I, you have probably noticed,
have dipped out of making as many videos as I used to because
I just don't know where I fit in?
I feel a little overwhelmed, I feel a
little, um, confused as to how
I wanna create content... so
I thought, these are the types of videos that it seems
like people...
are watching way more on youtube these
days, so I-I, I'm gonna try
my hand at them. Squad
squad squad squad squad squad
Squad. Oh my god! Uh squad. F**k.
Squad. Squaaad. My ah, ugh. F**k
Okay better light, here we go, ready. Squad!
Why aren't you being
more like Rylan? Why aren't you being cuter?
Do something better! Squad. Squad. Squad? Okay,
squad you're eating so I caught you at a time that
makes sense for us to talk. The only time we talk is about,
about to eat, having eaten,
waiting for food, or just recently digested, so
we are ready squad!
Squad? Can you just giggle at a high pitch?
Squad?
Got ittt! F**k. Shit
Ohhh, squad. We tried doing squad adventures, I.
The squad is fighting right now. We're fighting.
This is like real, real world, like
realer, real world, so
um, subscribe to that, cause this is realer
than the real world is, um. I know what you need. *sigh* We tried to go on adventures, that didnt work, I know what you need.
I got it, hold on.
Thats the sound of someone that wants some GUCCI SLIDES!
*rap music*
I don't have the f**king money for that, also
why, why? Lets DIY some gucci slides.
Symbolism, symbolism. Gucci slides have become a thing that
I have watched many youtubers desire,
buy, wear, make fun of, but still yet pay
money to wear, do not enjoy the actual day to day comfort level
of them, still payed money for them, still
promote them in a weird way that's, what the
actual f**k. Look. When I was in highschool I bought
Adidas *ooh sound effect* sandals,
which are exactly like these gucci slides *WHAT?*
that everyone wants to wear and they were like forty
dollars and that was luxury to me.
These gucci slides  *oh no sound effect*. They're eleven hundred
and fifty dollars. One thousand
one hundred
and fifty dollars
We're gonna keep up with the things youtube promotes.
"We're gonna hit a million subscribers and I told her she needs to splurge.
She's been looking at these Gucci slides
for literally months." "You're turning into ricegum
with like Gucci Slides
"No! But they're cute, I think!"
And what people like on youtube? It's people wearing these
kind of shoes and talking about buying these kinds of shoes, so
lets DIY some Gucci slides super quickly.
I have these slippers. Isotoners
Spare, no expense. I know. Sorry.
Unrelateable how expensive these are!
Coles, 40% off maybe, if you're lucky!
We're gonna take these, and turn them
into some Gucci slides. I have this silver paper.
I don't want these to look stupid!
I don't want these to be, dumb
or uncomfortable, or impractical by any means!
I wanna get my eleven hundred and
fifty dollars worth of
*echo effect* sandals.
Gucci slides!! Hey guys,
so one of my squad members, Goose,
has no idea that I got
her Gucci slides. She has no idea. I forgot where, okay.
Oh my. I've never done anything like this, I've never, okay.
She's over there and she's listening to me describe this so
hold on, pretend she's not there and I'm just gonna set this up.
We're gonna pretend like, this is a real thing.
Everyone, shut the, Goose can you wait
I have to set the lights up
If you're gonna be in this squad, you have to like
Go in the other room.
Yeah, you have to go in the other room. Here go.
Stay in here, just wait, stay. Stay. Ready?
Ready?
Come on out Goose!
I got you Gucci slides!
Yay!
*rap music plays* I got you Gucci slides!
I got you expensive things!
Look!
Put them on!
Wear them!
Be funny about
them!
Yeah!
Oh! Gucci Slides! Gucci Slides!
You wanna have like a connection with me as a human, no!
Look at the tangible product things!
Dont try
to interact with me as
a physical human
and create connections and relationships!
No! Take the,
get the exp,
eleven hundred and fifty dollars!
I don't have a camera man so hold on.
Eleven hundred and fifty dollars! Eleven hundred and fifty dollars!
Oh, um, um, uh parenthesis emotional.
Parenthesis emotional.
Parenthesis emotional guys I had no idea that she'd
have this kind of reaction
Oh, parenthesis emotional.
Um, she can't, she can't even touch 'em.
Oh, parenthesis! Hey guys! I don't know what day it is
of the week, I keep forgetting, um, but I'll put it
in a cute little thing right down there, uh.
Oh my god this week has been insane!
I have new merch coming out that I,
I mean you guys saw. *hamster-like sounds*
Oh my god! I just saw samples of my new merch
and its. Insayno banayno!
*hamster sounds*
*more hamster sounds*
*awkward laughter*
*even more hamster sounds*
*eeven more hamster sounds*
*too many hamster sounds*
Oh my god you guys know me.
You don't know me you've never met face to face but like
you know me!
Oh my god! *hamster sound*
If you know me then you know I like wearing clothes *hamster sound*
clothes, that I make money off of
selling to you guys so oh my
god! I've been working for-EVERR
on these designs. *croak sigh*
I cannot wait for you to see them, they're gonna look like
a lot of other shirts that you've seen,
or clothes that you've seen but like, I've
put my blood sweat and tears behind it!
I can't even hold my camera to
the angle where I can see my face.
Squad? Squad. Hey! Do you want a summer bod
aka. a summer body?
Not a summer.
Ow!
*fake laughter*
Act like we have had a
conversation
before the camera turned on. Yeah, Goose! I also do
want a summer bod! How do I get it? This
fun, fit, fab,
five minute summer workout. Let's do it in five seconds!
Ow it hurts!
My  own workout hurts
me! It's gonna hurt you.
Uh, twelve!
Thirteen.
Seventeen. Planks!
Woah, cool!
If you do that,
you did that. Hi guys! It's me.
Welcome back to my video where I try to put.
*fake awkward laugh*
I have a friend off
camera
that's equally as broken as me.
They're gonna help me place blame on a system
that helped me get where I am but like, not(?).  *more fake laughter*
I taught myself as a role model,
even though,
I deeply don't believe that in myself.
Oh f**k! I'm gonna tell you some f**ked up
shit that has affected me
permanently, but I'm gonna say in a really
funny tone with all my friends off camera, they're gonna laugh at
it and we're all
gonna think it's funny and not that it has
affected me completely,
for the rest of my life. *fake laughter*
Wow.
I thought I did great. Ten
million views across the board. Let me know in
the comments down below, what type
of video you want me to try to make in the future
and let me know in the comments down below, if
you,
are, if you feel, um
good. If you, if you watch a
youtube video you feel whole and good
and like its helping your, like let me know in the comments down below
if you watch
a youtube video and you,
you, you feel genuinely, you feel like
everyone involved is genuinely, like,
let me know in the comments down below, if you watch a youtube video
and you think that, you, you genuinely,
like,
you, like, use, like, let me know in the comments down
below if you genuinely have, um, a
connection to a person.
I don't know.
Okay, squad, squad, squad, squad, squad, squad.
Where, sq.
Goose you're my f**king squad so, have
literally just choose one of the spice girls
kind of personalities and then like make it
more bland than that. Come! on! Okay,
do you wanna be the one that laughs, that really
does all the background work, do you wanna be the cute one, or do you wanna be like
the one that you're like "oh that one's gonna like
cause trouble" or do you wanna be the one that's just
added so that the other people feel comfortable.